hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and with the final
saga upon us we need to talk about one
of the most badass characters in one
piece and someone who is about to play a
major role in the conclusion of the
story luffy's grandpa monkey d garp the
hero of the marines was a key player in
the mysterious god valley incident he is
about to be a key player in the
conclusion of one piece as the truth
about god valley is finally revealed and
he is way stronger and way more
important to the story than most people
realized so let's break it down if you
guys enjoy our one piece content and you
want us to keep it going leave a quick
like and comment right now and of course
if you haven't already don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications it's a
completely free way of directly
supporting the channel right now and if
you want to be a badass hero like garp
with a bunch of beautiful waifus under
your command then you'll love the
sponsor of this video mobile legends
adventure mobile legends adventure is a
free-to-play idol strategy rpg that's
easy to get into and fits perfectly into
a busy daily schedule choose from over
100 unique heroes each with their own
set of skills stories and epic
animations that go along with their
ultimate moves seriously these
animations make me feel like i'm
actually watching an anime in the middle
of a fight collect idle rewards to level
up your heroes and develop the strongest
squad without having to grind for
resources and the game never gets boring
because strategy is such an important
aspect of the game heroes come in 5
different classes and 7 different
factions and even if you have a lower
battle power than your opponent a smart
hero formation can still lead to victory
you can also explore dungeons solve
mazes and participate in awesome events
like the summer island party event which
starts on august 26th this event has the
biggest rewards yet you can claim 100
free summons and thousands of diamonds
and there will be new summer skins
available for a limited time only so be
sure to grab them before the event is
over support the channel by downloading
mobile legends adventure and assembling
your own squad right now just click the
top link in the description or use the
qr code on screen finally this video may
contain one piece manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned marine vice admiral monkey d
garp is not only one of the strongest
and most famous marines in history but
he is also the father of the world's
most wanted criminal monkey d dragon the
grandfather of the new yonko monkey d
luffy and the adoptive grandfather of
portcast d ace the infamous second
division commander of the whitebeard
pirates and the biological son of goldie
roger garp has already had a massive
impact on the world of one piece and
during his long career he engaged in
battle against some of the most
legendary pirates who ever lived
including goldie roger rox d zebek kaido
whitebeard big mom and more garp is also
keeping multiple important secrets that
could shake the entire world of one
piece to its core and as the story
reaches its ultimate climax these
secrets will definitely be revealed and
the consequences of these reveals will
be mind-blowing and yet because the
one-piece story primarily follows luffy
and the straw hat pirates it's easy to
forget about garp and just how much he
knows just how strong he is and just how
important his character will be to the
overall narrative on top of that while
there is often a lot of hype in the one
piece community surrounding the marine
admirals the fact is power but we can't
forget that garp was actually offered
the rank of admiral multiple times
throughout his career
and he deliberately refused this
promotion every single time garp is not
a vice admiral because he isn't strong
enough to become an admiral in fact he
is likely stronger than the admirals
themselves garp is not an admiral
because he refused to become one and the
reason for his refusal is the key to
unraveling the mystery of garp's
character in order to unravel this
mystery we need to travel 38 years into
the past when a much younger garp
engaged in an epic battle to the death
against some of the most powerful
pirates in history on a mysterious
island known as god valley garp is
currently 78 years old and he joined the
marines 56 years ago at the age of 22.
he was in the same generation as former
fleet admiral sengoku and it was 38
years ago that garp truly made a name
for himself as one of the strongest and
most famous marines of all time this era
of history is sometimes referred to as
the era of rocks due to the fact that it
was dominated by the legendary pirate
rox d zebek and his crew the rock's
pirates some 44 years ago zebek formed
an incredibly overpowered crew on the
pirate island of hachinosu this crew
included a young white beard kaido big
mom shiki silver axe wang ji and captain
john
among others they terrorized the seas
for six years until everything finally
came to a head at god valley 38 years
ago zebek and the rock's pirates
attacked a mysterious island called god
valley and according to sengoku multiple
celestial dragons were present on the
island at the time of the attack along
with their slaves we don't know why they
were there or who they were but we know
that it was extremely important for the
world government to protect these
celestial dragons and to put a stop to
the rock's pirates
we know this because not only did the
world government unleash a powerful
contingent of marines to fight against
zebek and his crew a contingent which
included vice admiral garp himself but
they also did something that would have
been considered unimaginable under any
other circumstances the world government
actually teamed up with one of its
mortal enemies goldie roger and the
roger pirates in order to take zebic
down together garp and roger were the
ones who led the fight against the rox
pirates and according to former fleet
admiral sengoku roger and garp along
with many pirates and marines under
their command ultimately won the battle
zebek was apparently killed the rock's
pirates were disbanded and garp earned
his legendary title hero of the marines
unfortunately we know very little about
what happened during the battle itself
and this lack of information is very
much intentional on oda's part i am
convinced that the truth about what
really happened at god valley will be
revealed during the final saga and that
this reveal will have a massive impact
on the rest of the story the only
specific detail that we know about the
battle at god valley is that big mom
apparently saved kaido's life by giving
him his devil fruit the uhnomi model
seiru this suggests that kaido's life
was in direct danger and that eating the
devil fruit somehow saved him we also
know that after the battle the truth
about the entire incident was hushed up
by the world government the fact that
they worked together with the roger
pirates was heavily censored and the
entire island of god valley apparently
vanished from the face of the earth
today this island cannot even be found
on any map and although many assume that
the island was just destroyed with a
buster call that is not actually what
sengoku says he says that the island
disappeared entirely meaning that it
wasn't just heavily damaged with bombs
and left in ruins it just straight up
vanished what really happened to god
valley is a source of much speculation
and debate among the one-piece fandom
and i've heard everything from god
valley disappeared beneath the sea and
god valley was caught up in the knock-up
stream to god valley was made invisible
using the power of a devil fruit and god
valley is actually a moving island like
thriller bark so what exactly happened
at god valley and 2god valley remains a
mystery but i believe that we will
finally get these answers in the final
saga despite the fact that the god
valley incident occurred 38 years ago
the truth about what happened there will
have a profound impact on the present
and garp is the key to everything we
know that roger is no longer among the
living sengoku stated that zebek is no
longer among the living either and the
new generations of marines don't even
seem to know anything about god valley
this means that garp is one of the very
few people still alive today who know
the full truth and this secret knowledge
that garp possesses is sure to come into
play very soon the true origins of
shanks and buggy and how they ended up
on roger's ship at such a young age
could be directly tied to god valley the
truth about blackbeard and the
connection to zebek may also be
connected to god valley and don't even
get me started on the theories that
luffy's parents may have actually met
during this incident although the
theories are abundant one thing is for
sure the fact that garp and roger
managed to defeat the rock's pirates
means that they were both extremely
strong zebek terrorized the world for
years he was ruthless and unforgiving
and he was willing to attack even the
celestial dragons which as we know is
the gravest sin that anyone can commit
according to the rules of that world
zebek also formed a crew that included
three future yonko and other future
legends of piracy and yet garp and roger
came out on top and the fact that
sengoku mentions garp and roger
specifically as the biggest heroes of
that fight tells us that garp's strength
at that point was at least on par with
roger we can safely assume that there
were many other pirates and marines
there on that day but roger and garp are
the ones who got the vast majority of
the credit and since we know that
sengoku is not the type to lie about
things like this we have to assume that
all of that credit was well earned now
garp doesn't actually talk about god
valley and sengoku believes that there
are two distinct reasons for this first
garp doesn't want to admit that he was
forced to team up with a notorious
pirate like roger second garp really
dislikes the celestial dragons so he
doesn't want to talk about how he
actually saved a bunch of them at god
valley despite the fact that they are
terrible people and literal slave owners
in fact in chapter 957
sengoku confirms that the real reason
why garp continues to refuse to be
promoted to admiral is because admirals
are under the direct command of the
celestial dragons and garp simply
refuses to serve directly under them
this refusal by garp is in itself
considered to be a great insult to the
mighty celestial dragons and yet garp is
so strong and so important to the
marines that despite the fact that he
keeps refusing these offers which is
definitely considered disrespectful no
one in the world government wants to
fire him or do anything to him so he
remains a vice admiral there could also
be some other more secret reasons as to
why garp doesn't talk about god valley
but we'll have to wait and see again
though all of this confirms that garp
has been at the level of an admiral for
many years but he simply refuses to be
promoted in fact i would argue that garp
is actually stronger than the admirals
he was already at the level of an
admiral decades ago and since that time
he had many opportunities to get even
stronger and to perfect all of his
techniques now it is true that garp has
also gotten older meaning that he may no
longer be as strong as he was in his
prime but he still appears to be in
great shape and this is one piece where
the restrictions of age are not exactly
realistic after all during the marine
fort arc whitebeard was only a few years
younger than garp and he also had
serious medical conditions that required
constant treatment and yet he showed an
absolutely unbelievable level of
strength and resilience oh and of course
garp also showed himself to be a force
to be reckoned with at marineford so
with all of these things in mind i'm
inclined to believe that despite being
older garp is now probably even stronger
than he was at god valley and his level
of power surpasses that of an admiral in
the decades that followed god valley
garp demonstrated many other impressive
feats eight years after the god valley
incident he earned the name garp the
fist after absolutely wrecking qin zhao
and flattening his pointy drill-shaped
head which up to that point was known as
the strongest head in the world and it
could literally drill through an
incredibly thick layer of ice like it
was butter xinjiao was so devastated by
his defeat at the hands of garp that he
swore revenge not only against garp but
also against garp's son and grandson and
garp's defeat of xinjiao was only the
beginning garp would face off against
goldie roger multiple times between the
time of the god valley incident and
roger's death and each time garp turned
out to be a fierce opponent for the
overpowered roger pirates in fact roger
respected garp so much that he asked him
to take care of his unborn son ace after
roger's own impending death you can only
imagine how much roger must have
respected garp if he decided to entrust
his own son to the man who should have
been his mortal enemy roger clearly knew
that garp was both extremely honorable
and morally upright and also that he was
strong enough to protect ace from even
the fiercest threats about a week before
roger's public execution garp and
sengoku successfully repelled the direct
attack on marine ford by shiki the
golden lion proving once again that garp
is one of the strongest characters in
the entire world of one piece after the
death of roger garp would take ace to
don island where he was raised by curly
d'addan and where he eventually
befriended luffy and sabo garp also took
an active role in training young luffy
and ace in order to make them stronger
later on garp would also train kobe and
helmepo in their career as marines these
two then went through one of the
greatest chat formations in the history
of anime and manga and considering how
strong luffy and ace would eventually
become we have to conclude that garp is
one of the greatest instructors in all
of fiction although to be fair an
important part of garp's training regime
is almost killing his trainees on
multiple occasions but still garp would
argue that he is one of the main reasons
why luffy became as strong as he did we
can assume that garp also played a part
in training his son monkey d dragon who
would eventually become the leader of
the revolutionaries and the world's most
wanted man as i mentioned earlier during
the world shaking paramount war garp
demonstrated that he is still an
incredibly strong fighter even at his
advanced age at marine ford we see him
squaring off against the whitebeard
pirates who are determined to rescue ace
before his execution and we even see
garp punching out marco in his phoenix
form marco was at the time one of the
strongest pirates in the world and a
user of an overpowered mythical zone
devil fruit and yet garp who was already
in his mid-70s at the time appeared to
be more than a match for marco in fact
garp was clearly going easy on some of
his opponents during this battle because
he loves luffy and ace and he didn't
want either of them to get hurt when
luffy was attempting to reach ace and
save him garp stood in his way but when
it came down to actually fighting luffy
garp closed his eyes and allowed himself
to be hit by luffy and by doing this he
deliberately cleared the path for his
grandson if garp had been fighting
seriously and giving it his all
throughout the course of this battle
things would have gone a lot worse for
luffy and the pirates garp wasn't even
really fazed by luffy's direct attack
because later on he and sengoku would
face off against blackbeard and the
blackbeard pirates when ace was
ultimately killed by sakazuki garp flew
into a rage and he would have killed
sakazuki if sengoku wasn't there to hold
him down knowing everything that we know
about garb i think that he was indeed
capable of killing sakazuki and there is
a real possibility that garp is actually
stronger than the current fleet admiral
after the events of marine ford both
garp and sengoku resigned from their
positions within the marines
however the two of them resigning at the
same time at such a crucial turning
point in history would have looked
extremely bad for the world government
so the world government military
commander-in-chief kong didn't allow
them to leave the service instead they
retained their ranks and they were put
in charge of training the next
generation of marines as we saw during
the recent reverie and wano arcs garp
remains involved in marine activities
especially activities related to
diplomacy i believe that garp is
currently biding his time and that he
has a secret plan up his sleeve a plan
that likely also involves sengoku in my
opinion
garp will finally make his move against
the celestial dragons during the final
saga and it is at that time that we will
finally learn the truth about god valley
and the full extent of garp's power and
speaking of garp's power how strong is
he really we know that garp is a living
legend among the marines and one of the
strongest marines in history he was able
to go toe-to-toe against the pirate king
goldie roger on multiple occasions
together with roger he defeated the
rock's pirates he also defeated xinjiao
he slapped marco in his phoenix form and
together with sengoku he defeated cheeky
carp could have been promoted to admiral
decades ago if he had wanted to and i
think it's likely that he would actually
take all the current admirals in a fight
he has demonstrated superhuman feats of
strength on multiple occasions like
breaking walls with his fists and
effortlessly throwing a gigantic ball
and chain at the thousand sunny garp is
even said to have crushed entire
mountains with his punch he also has
exceptional stamina and durability as we
saw during the paramount war he was able
to take a direct punch from luffy in
gear second and then get up a little bit
later to fight blackbeard garp also
possesses exceptional speed and just in
general his power is highly respected by
everyone from the very top echelons of
the world government to the strongest
pirates in history like roger and
whitebeard aside from using cannonballs
and a giant ironball and chain as
weapons garp can also use both armament
hockey and observation hockey although
he hasn't been shown to be a user of
conquerors haki he is extremely
knowledgeable about it and according to
garp he could sense that luffy had the
ability to use conquerors haki ever
since he was born i believe that garp is
easily one of the top 10 strongest
living characters in one piece and
although we are yet to see the full
extent of his power i am convinced that
his true power will be revealed in the
final saga of the story i think that
garp is planning something big i think
that he will turn against the celestial
dragons when the time is right and when
this does happen we will finally learn
the truth about the infamous god valley
incident in my opinion garp truly
believes that the marines are a force
for good in the world and that they can
make the world a better place but at the
same time he knows that the world
government and the celestial dragons are
a force for evil and so in order to save
the marines and the rest of the world i
think garp will betray the world
government and i think that sengoku kobe
helmepo and others will join him in fact
i wouldn't be surprised if garp ends up
being the one who kills sakazuki in the
final arc of the story we all know that
luffy wants revenge for what happened to
ace but sakazuki being taken out by garp
would be even more poetic in my opinion
mark my words guys do not
sleep on garp he will turn out to be far
stronger and far more important to the
story than most people realize let me
know what you think how strong is garp
and where would you rank him among the
top strongest characters in the series
do you agree with me that he breaks into
the top 10 living characters and who are
your top 10 comment down below with your
thoughts and rankings if you enjoy our
one piece content and you want to see
more in the future you know what to do
leave a quick like and comment right now
and of course if you haven't subscribed
yet make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications it is a
completely free way to directly support
this channel and you might think that
subscribing doesn't mean a lot but it
actually does help a whole bunch on
youtube you can also hit me up on
twitter and instagram at animeopror
thanks again to mobile legends adventure
for sponsoring this video check them out
link in the description as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see ya space cowboys